all right tonight the food network
showcasing some local las vegas baker's
talented women right here in its big
baked halloween show we are so excited
to have you three on the show this
morning to talk about the experience and
then we're gonna get some tips on
actually decorating corey wells with
wistful thinking cakes kristy horner of
rock sugar custom cakes and we also have
kristin hutton there at the end with
decorate me so ladies the three of you
joined forces and you
ended up getting on this food network
show how in the world does that even
happen um kind of crazy we got invited
by a casting agent to apply and we
thought
why not right and not what's the worst
that could happen and we got on and it
was incredible and so i know you can't
give any spoilers we're looking at some
pictures actually of the the bake off
we'll call it the decorating contest
itself i know you can't tell us kind of
what's going to happen but we can tell
people to tune in tonight because it's
the premiere and they'll get to see you
guys yeah yeah premiere tonight you'll
get to see all the fun and the mishaps
and like the things that you know kind
of go on in those type of events and
we're super proud of what we did oh i
bet you are uh overall corey a good
experience excellent excellent we would
be back in a heartbeat yeah we loved it
a little nerve-wracking though do you
suppose of course of course wouldn't you
guys say like probably like one of the
frustrations
one of the frustrating and like
nerve-wracking but
totally awesome but look at you now
you're absolutely prepared to be here
live on television with us this morning
decorating with fondant fondant i always
say i knew i was going to say it wrong
what's the key here to decorating as as
you ladies are kind of doing some fun
stuff here with piping
um i think one of the keys with fondant
is to just make sure that you need it
really well before you use it it has a
tendency to crack if you just kind of
use it straight out of the bucket
but if you if you work it a little bit
before you mold anything then it's that
kind of helps and you're making little
pumpkins there i am yeah that was so
cute
here uh tell me now you've got a whole
arsenal of tools here what what are the
key components for anybody who wants to
do something fancy well that's the thing
you need some good tools these are
silicone tools that
it just really helps kind of mold
everything
and make
everything look good oh there we go
we've got the overhead camera which is
kind of cool kind of shows exactly what
you guys are up to this is a a skill
that not many of us have how did you
guys master this um is it something that
you just have always been interested in
um i went to school for children's book
illustrations so i'm actually fine art
by trade i started making my kids cakes
and i was like you know i think i like
this more than painting and and you just
opened up your business um in may i did
congratulations thank you that is on the
west side of the valley southwest side
southwest side chopping fort apache
and we are just loving every minute i
still walk in it's like a dream come
true i can't believe it's mine you did
it and both of you ladies kristen
christie uh you guys are doing um
uh orders and stuff out of your homes
that's your business operation yes we
have uh cottage licenses to work out of
our homes wonderful and so for people
who are interested obviously i know we
can find yours cory very easily ladies
um instagram internet all that kind of
stuff all the things
wonderful i love this it is absolutely
beautiful
i'm just blown away by the talent here
folks at home okay so tonight food
network the show is going to premiere
you get to see las vegas on stage
i i'm going to cross my fingers for a
win here i know you can't tell me yeah
hopefully we'll be able to have you guys
back maybe with a big trophy like our
lady aces all right
congratulations thank you huge success
thank you for being here on the show
this morning good day is going to